la téléconsultation une alternative
plébiscitée en période de coronavirus en
france la pratique est expérimenté
depuis les années soixante à distance le
chirurgien chef d'un centre de
traumatologie dirige ce diagnostic en
image précise la nature des premiers
soins à apporter aux blessés dans les
années 60 la consultation à distance et
est principalement utilisé pour les
accidents de la route
je vous prie pour mes charges les
données médicales étaient transmises en
direct depuis le lieu de l'accident
un médecin guidait les ambulanciers
continuer la respiration avec l'en but
faites attention qu'il n'y a pas
d'obstacles dans les voies respiratoires
supérieures sur l'état reste toujours un
cru inquiétant à cause de ce rythme
respiratoire
pour consulter à distance le téléphone
faisait partie des indispensables en
1972 ce cardiologue recevait des
résultats grâce un signal transmis par
téléphone
l'électrocardiogramme est tout à fait
normal jusque journée les relations très
cordiales ya pas de commentaire tout va
très bien merci bonsoir ce dispositif
permettait aussi de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux ou d'apple pour le
contrôle de rappel
autre exemple en 1973 de chez lui
cet homme voulait s'assurer du
fonctionnement de son pacemaker
on peut y aller c'est prêt
dans les années 80 grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
la télémédecine se faisait à plus grande
distance à dix mille kilomètres de là à
londres le docteur andrew valence owen
chirurgien examine l'enfant presque
comme s'il était dans son cabinet sur
des images fixes mais précise et sur des
radios et il peut même dialoguer avec le
médecin traitant
aujourd'hui la télé consultation est
accessible à tous
médecins et patients l'acte est au même
prix qu'une consultation classique
[Musique]